because I I live in Japan so I don't
have to show my passport when I check in
sometimes I want to see my cards my
residence card for living here sometimes
they don't technically they're not
supposed to ask and they're not supposed
to copy it it's just a whole some hotels
ask for some hotels don't you can be
pushy about it and say don't do it but
then it like it gets even weirder when
you're traveling with people who do need
to show their passports and it was
always like hey we wanted to offer a
great service where we take the bags to
the room they'd be like hey so before we
check in can we see everyone's passports
I'm like oh but passports are in the
bags that you took took yeah yeah and
they're all like oh oh well could you
could you like come back later and scan
them right I was like all right just
never did yeah and I was like it's weird
why do they it's like I have I have like
a different problem every time I go into
a hotel where it's like you know usually
other people right they're like oh can
we see your passports or if you live in
Japan can we at least see us idiot card
all your resume yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it's so awkward every time like
everyone's you know giving like this
happened and so much on journey across
Japan everyone's giving those I do cards
right and then the cloaks just like you
know looks over at me being like Zodi
card [__] and I and it's so awkward me
having to be like yes I don't have one
uh I'm Japanese I can see them pressing
X like it's a doubt they're like you
sure about that [__] oh you knew
horns
what's up how does this interaction
normally go oh no I mean for the most
part it's usually I just say oh I'm
Japanese in Japanese and they're like
yeah oh okay I'm gonna [__] try that
yeah I'm gonna say it see if they stop
asking me for my document yes but then
every now and then when it's like
especially in like if it's like a big
city for example with lots of foreigners
they they're kind of just like what do
you mean by that
like what do you mean you're Japanese
research music and I'm like uh so I just
don't I don't have a anxiety record I I
live here I have yeah well I think I
actually did like I I don't I'm not 100
sure on this but I'm pretty sure even if
you live here that you're like they're
not required to have your ID no but
again I guess how do you like take my
word for it like I guess I guess I have
to do that I'm like they're like no
you're not Japanese you clearly don't
look yeah I am just trust you know I've
got chatting with some people who uh
have Zion cards and they really don't
like I guess because it's just like the
principle they don't want to show them
yeah like I'm actually half a shirt [__]
you yeah they're like no I'm not sure
anymore because also they always have
photocopy it as well yeah which I don't
get why do they photocopy my car yeah
I'm like I don't I guess maybe it's for
like uh like insurance reasons maybe I
guess but it's like if you kind of [__]
up a room so hard then it's like oh we
got your infrared here a little bit you
know a little bit xenophobic to just
only get like the foreign residence I
guess it's kind of weird yeah so they
can actually if it's a police officer
they're gonna take you
yeah yeah yeah
you just say like all Japanese to it but
like everyone else that woke me up but
if it's a police officer yeah no no no
police officer yeah they can actually
you obviously yeah but like checking
into a hotel I think there if if you
want to you don't have to prove that
you're but I guess yeah it's hard for
them as well right well there you go
life hack next time you're at a hotel
just be like nihonjin this yeah
coming up to the hotel by the way this
is it's weird because like normally
whenever I travel for work in Japan like
we're filming stuff yeah yeah I don't
know if it's I noticed that
um this is such a a expat [__]
problem if you're like booking.com is
still set to the foreign country they'll
they'll 100 ask you for idea when you
get there but yeah because I change
because Chris hasn't done it Chris is
still set to like the UK yeah and I told
him like a million times to change that
[__] because every time we go to a place
they immediately ask for our passports
yeah yeah it's super annoying having to
like do the whole thing uh I sent mine
to Japan now so that when I book it
sometimes they ask sometimes they don't
but actually just trip no one ever asked
me for it oh that's good and no one ever
tried to photocopy it and I was like oh
this is a nice change of Base that's
what they should do it every holiday
yeah I'm like chill nice sick awesome
coming up with the times I don't know I
just it's just it just saves time I just
don't wanna dude it's so annoying when
you when we were cycling every single
day on the cycle yeah this 30 minute
[__] check-in where they want to
scan all my documents make sure I'm like
legal and it's like oh my god dude like
let me just check I don't need a shower
dude I smell like [__] let me in the
room
it's like I don't know I it's it's weird
I guess especially if like I I don't
actually I wonder if it's something to
do with paying afterwards and paying
um before because all the hotels I paid
before uh and when we did uh when we
traveled uh with Chris or whatever we
always pay after I just also one of the
hotels Chris did forget to pay oh [__]
it was an apple Hotel hey Chris forgot
to pay because she straight up forgot to
pay I just left we were late to the
stream because Chris had to drive back
and go and pay because they called him
up and they were like oh assume I was in
uh money where the [__]
so Chris would drive back and go and pay
because he's just straight up laughed
how many hotels has that man been in how
did you forget this is why when I book
it I just pay right there I'm like this
takes away a giant stress yeah yeah uh
it's just so much easier because you're
gonna pay with the same [__] card
anyway you don't wanna pay up front yeah
you don't want to [__] around like as
you're leaving you're probably like
rushing to go somewhere or you know
whatever just like booking.com more
often not just it gives you like a two
percent discount anyway yeah yeah
anyway yeah
um so you know it's so annoying anyway
so this is such a person living here
problem and even then a more Niche
problem of person living here who
travels around here a lot probably yeah
gig of first world problems
have you ever like you know when uh
whenever you're like living in Australia
or something or somewhere outside of
Japan have you ever like had an
opportunity to help a Japanese tourist
abroad that's like yeah a few times
um but I don't know it's it's weird like
unlike in Japan where there are a lot of
people who come to Japan not knowing the
language whatsoever yeah and are like
clearly struggling yeah a lot of
Japanese people who come to Australia
they're deep they're pretty decent at
English like enough where they can kind
of get around because I feel like for
English mentality yeah I should think
that you'll be accommodated right and I
think like especially with like Japanese
people because for the most part a lot
of Japanese people are like the the
common consensus is like they're very
afraid to like travel overseas because
it's like oh you know Japanese doesn't
really work yeah anywhere else outside
of Japan right so it's like I feel the
people who are actually willing to
travel outside of Japan to different
countries are the ones that are already
probably interested in like learning
English or like learning a different
language anyway yeah so like I've never
had that thing of like I've seen a
clearly Japanese tourist yeah in
Australia struggling because it's like
well you probably know the bare minimum
English to get around anyway yeah so
it's like yeah you'll be all right just
got out I had a moment I was like so
proud of it was just like it made living
here in Japan for like four years worth
it just for this like one moment just
because uh it was actually when I went
to Thailand at last time yeah and uh uh
we were at the airport we're just Garden
off the plane uh and uh our Sydney was
in the toilet so I was waiting for her
and I could see there there's there was
this like older Japanese couple talking
to one of the Thai staff members uh and
I I you know I just kind of like zoned
in on like their conversation and I
think they were like trying to find kind
of like the right gate to transfer over
to because they were flying to like one
of the islands or something now like you
said they could speak like a little bit
of English yeah but it wasn't great yeah
but also the person that was uh kind of
helping them obviously Tai yeah her
English wasn't great either yeah I saw
this so much it was like a different
tourist trying to speak English to a
Japanese person who also had batting
yeah yeah yeah it was it was like a car
crash every time so it was just like
confusion on both sides there was a Thai
person speaking broken English to a
broken English older Japanese couple who
couldn't also speak English trying to
best interpret that so I was just like
you know what I think this is my moment
I I think I think this is my moment and
so I come over and uh I you know I I ask
to the person I tell the person inside
is everything okay I can speak like a
little bit of Japanese and she explains
to me oh you know I'm trying to explain
to them the directions of the gate and
the plane that I can get to and I was
like thank God I can actually my
language skills are good enough to like
translate this and then and then so I
translate them to uh I say what she says
in Japanese and they go
it's like why do you want to yeah yeah
exactly exactly and I was and then they
were like oh why do you speak Japanese
and I was like oh I'm I just literally
flew flew from Japan I live in Japan
right now uh I had a nice pleasant
conversation and I was like yeah you go
here you go there I hope you have a nice
Journey here and I hope you have a nice
day in Thailand and it was just like
that was that was I don't know sometimes
it's the little things of life and I
just I was like beaming I was beaming
all day just because that one
interaction I was like I was like yes
it's so weird because like in Australia
I've had so many instances where it's
like it's that situation but flipped
yeah so it's like I I could be like
walking around in you know somewhere in
Sydney like somewhere where I'm like
clearly know where I'm going maybe I'm a
little bit lost you know maybe it's
because it's like a suburb I've never
been to yeah and I've had people who you
know mistake me for a different
nationality many times right uh I
remember one time I was in I forgot
where I even was but it was a place I'd
never been to before and I was like
looking for a particular I think like
restaurant or something to meet up with
a friend
and I'm like where the [__] is this
place and I'm like looking on my phone I
don't know where it is yeah and this
like dude just he's just like excuse me
and he just comes up to me it's just
like I think he was like Indian or you
know maybe like you know Pakistani
something like that yeah and he just
starts speaking to me in Hindi
I know how am I looking
I love your movies yeah he just starts
speaking to me in Hindi and I'm like and
and I tried to tell him I was like uh
I'm sorry man I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about and he just
and he's like oh oh you speak English
yeah and I'm like yeah I speak English I
don't speak whatever the [__] you just
spoke to me yeah and he was like trying
it's like oh it looked like yeah it's
like I thought you were like a like an
Indian tourist or something like trying
to figure out where you wanted to go and
I'm like dude that's my fear of like
helping who I think is a Japanese person
yeah they just speak a completely
different language yeah oh [__] okay
I've had that so many times where I
thought they were Japanese and they were
like Korean yeah yeah and I'm just like
oh sorry I've I've had that so many
songs where I've uh gone to a place
thought they were Thai and uh it turns
out they were Vietnamese I literally
when we were when we were on our America
Tour I think we were in like New Jersey
or something it was like our day off and
now you guys have got to get dinner and
I'm like I I [__] miss Thai food man
I just want some Thai food sure go to
the local Thai restaurant
Southeast Asian guy serves me and I'm
like oh my God I'm back home and I start
speaking to him in Thai and he's just
like uh sorry I I don't speak till I I'm
uh I'm Malaysian I'm like God God damn
it man I thought I was home right now
I thought I was uh everyone gets
confused food is gonna be whack or good
it was still good though God just
immediately walks out
send it back yeah I thought I was home
baby but I thought it felt great bro it
felt like my third eye was had to open
because this was the first situation I'd
ever been in my life where I had not
used my first language I I had used my I
guess my second language and now my
third language and I'm just like yo is
this the power of a trilingual
validation yeah yeah yeah yeah have I
have I unlocked the trilingual power now
oh my God this feels incredible yeah but
uh yeah hopefully hopefully that that
kind of like little moments like that
I'm just like oh I should I should study
more Japanese now yeah that's like
reignited my passion for yeah like
hearing stories like that makes me want
to learn a third language but I just
don't know what yeah
to counteract okay dude it's got to be
handy bro
like what funny you say that actually uh
bro imagine how big your fan base would
get if you knew him you would be huge
you would quadruple your viewership bro
it would be game changing extra one
billion fans